hey youtubers is Charlie so we had a
speed force intervention episode of the
flash careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet there's a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video so it is like a
party in the speedforce
everybody that died in previous seasons
come back and say hi to Barry while he
figures out that he needs to be the one
to stops avatar so there are whole bunch
of comic book Easter eggs a lot of clues
and a lot of things but cast has said
about the reveal of savat are and when
it's coming so I'll try to explain that
while I'm doing my top 10 but number 10
the intro with Barry thinking at
SuperSpeed coming to the conclusion that
he needs to go into the Speed Force to
get Wally I love the way they jump
around like it's almost in slow motion
like they're shooting things from
Barry's perspective it's very similar to
the fight scene with savat are from last
week where they sort of freeze-frame and
your camera just kind of moves around
them because you put it more in their
perspective and this really was like a
headspace episode for Barry you have to
imagine that the Speed Force creates
things based on personal experiences
like Wally was trapped in his own
personal health Barry came back to the
place where he got his powers in his lab
it was that really quick hr- world
name-drop that's actually earth 383 from
the comics it showed up during crisis on
Infinite Earths it was basically just a
version of earth one with characters
that were still alive who had already
died on earth one so what a coincidence
that Supergirl is on the cover this is
actually a Supergirl story so just a
really funny week at her but number 9
Cisco vibes Barry into the Speed Force
and the interesting thing here obviously
Kim landing inside his lab the site of
the place that he got his powers is
really cool but what they're doing here
like the big change from the comics is
that they need help to get into and out
of the Speed Force in the comics you can
just go in you can come out however you
want you just have to be a powerful
enough speedster so either they're
following the comics and Barry just
isn't powerful enough yet or more likely
I think they're just using this so that
there's no easy way to save Jay Garrick
which I'll talk about later on my list
but it kind of explains house avatar got
stuck in there if he's so powerful to if
he's supposed to be even more powerful
than Barry then wouldn't he be able to
get out by himself like how is it that
Barry stuck them in that time loop to
begin with but number 8 welcome back
Eddie so
we finally find out what he was doing
when he came back to the show he's
speaking as the voice of the speedforce
they explain what the speedforce thought
of flashpoint they're like yeah you
totally messed up that was totally effed
up how you went back and changed time
after you told us that you were totally
fine with your mother died in his pissed
as they are they do say that they
totally understand why he did it which
is why they allowed it
we know zoom killed your father so
that's why we allowed you to go back but
there has to be consequences so this is
where you get to the idea of sticks
Barry has the powers of a god because he
can change time that's crazy powerful so
this is a shows way of keeping him from
getting Opie and they flat-out explain
to him through Eddie that we're going to
give you a lesson here there's something
you have to learn while you're trying to
get Wally back and it's not going to be
reading a children's story with your
mother it's going to be way harder this
time outrunning the time rate he makes
it to the next level of speedster hell I
know that should be heaven because
that's where speedsters go and they die
that's what the Speed Force is supposed
to be but I guess it could be hell - I
like the way they're ambiguous about
that like it's very specific to each
speedster that comes into the Speed
Force so number seven
welcome back Ronnie I was so surprised
when we saw him in the trailer I was
like oh my god we're going to get Ronnie
and Eddie back in the same episode and
it explains the creepy speedforce baby
so that was the baby that was going to
be born had he not died any T's up
surprised the black flash so I know a
lot of you were wondering what happened
to him because it seems like he
destroyed him but you can't really
destroy the black flash you can only
replace him we're sort of ties in
somatically with what was happening in
this episode like there has to always be
somebody trapped in this endless time
loop like there always has to be a black
flash so Barry was just sending him away
it's possible he could come back on one
of the TV shows because he's a really
powerful speedster you could use him
against avatar but there would have to
be a reason for him to manifest usually
he's a stand-in for the time race so if
something really bad is happening the
Speed Force will SiC the black flash on
you but they haven't done that dis
avatar yet which is an interesting twist
but I think it all goes in to the idea
of who's avatar is and why it's so
important that Barry be the one to stop
him but it was great seeing the black
flash again and
I love the way that Barry instantly
recognized him as zoom he didn't call
him the black flash he just called him
zoom next level of Hell deeper number
five welcome back Captain Cold
we still haven't gotten the real Captain
Cold alive in present day on one of the
shows yet they said that that's coming
relatively soon but it's fun the way
they've used him this season like he's
still dead but it's really easy to bring
him back as a Speed Force apparition or
is like a headcanon version in heatwaves
mind but the whole thing here is it it's
kind of a Ruth he's slowly trying to get
Barry to challenge the Speed Force and
sort of like come to the conclusion that
I'm not going to listen to anybody I'm
going to be the hero again
I'm going to save Wally that was the
whole point so that's why he smiled when
Barry challenged him but we got a lot of
explainers here we learned that this is
a temporal loop whoever's trapped in
their experiences their most painful
memory over and over again in for Wally
that's watching his mother die but don't
you wonder now what was savatage most
painful memory if being a speedster God
is his most important thing
maybe it's losing his powers like when
you're a speedster that's the most
special thing ever that was a big thing
for Wally earlier this season so let me
know in the comments what do you thinks
avatars most painful memory is number 4
welcome back Jay Garrick he was in all
the promotional photos so I had no idea
what he was going to be if he was going
to be another Speed Force person in the
episode but the plot twist was kind of
convenient because he says oh you know
off screen while he wasn't around Cisco
came got me
we jury-rigged my helmet so that you
guys can get out so there were a couple
of convenient plot twists like they
probably cut out a lot of those scenes
but even bigger twists number three was
Jesse quick versus savat are so you know
the great bite she holds him off but we
get this really creepy twist where he
says I have plans for you in the future
so we learned a whole bunch about his
armor about how he's a normal person
underneath which I feel like we kind of
already knew they showed us that
sequence whatever Jay Garrick was
explaining him how he was the first
person to get speed with the
Philosopher's Stone you see an actual
human person here who looks super jacked
but here's where we get into the idea of
different members of team flash learning
about the secret of savat are before
other members so the cast said that
people are going to learn at different
periods it's not like they're all going
to learn who Savage
is all at the same time so it sounds
like it's going to be some big WTF twist
and that might tie in with what the
plans for Jesse are because she's super
smart and she's a speedster so it sounds
like sabotage is going to try and twist
her to get her to do something for him
but she isn't having it so she goes to
earth 3 to take Jay Garrick's place is
the flash of that earth so she'll be
back eventually but even bigger WTF
number two is that Barry does save Wally
but only at the expense like this is
probably what's going to make people
really upset that Jay Garrick has to
take his spot in the Speed Force the
important takeaway from this though is
that he says for a little while not
forever so Jay Garrick is only going to
be stuck in there until Barry defeats
avatar which could be the end of the
season so I'm not expecting to see Jay
Garrick till the finale but I do think
that he'll come back like they're not
just going to leave him there till
season 4 and just make you wonder hey
what happened to him you know we puts
avatar back in there where Jay Garrick
go but the whole point of the episode
number 1 is in making Barry realized
that he has to be the one to defeats
avatar not Wally he can't push this off
on anyone else so he sort of refocuses
himself which I feel like everybody's
happy about the show is called the flash
even though HR was really cruel when he
shaded Jesse by saying when the real
flash gets back
technically Barry is the real flash so
as there is a big bag to be taken down
it's his responsibility even though it's
a team effort he needs to be the one to
do the deed and show everyone that he's
a hero he needs to inspire everyone the
way the Speed Force said that he
inspired captain colt I really liked
that line too do you know why snart
sacrificed himself because you inspired
him to be a hero it was also a nice
golden age easter egg from Captain Cold
he was trying to shade Jay Garrick just
because Jay Garrick is from the Golden
Age of the comics but now you kind of
understand why next week's episode is so
different in terms of tone because they
ended on like such a big moment that
they want to give people a break so
they're going to do that musical
crossover Barry is going to get stuck in
the dream I'll do a video for the
trailer explaining it in greater detail
basically Darren Criss you see Supergirl
here so it's going to be a lot of fun
it'll be sort of a break from all the
heavy stuff that went on then they'll
get back to their sabot our plotline and
when they say that Wally is riding the
bench for little
I think that's only going to be for a
couple episodes he'll definitely be back
by the finale remember this is only
episode 16 there are 23 episodes so it's
not like he's going to be sitting out
for the rest of the season well let me
know what you thought of the episode I
feel like it was pretty solid even
though it felt like a smaller episode in
terms of scope there was a lot of
information that they gave us though
abouts avatar about what happened in the
futures that Barry did to trap him there
but what will happen next is is I'll
post that flash trailer I have a Legion
video that I'm going to post I'll
explain some of the big things that are
happening on the show right now
so they also revealed some more stuff
about Thor Ragnarok so we got a whole
bunch of Marvel DC stuff coming between
the TV shows in the movie so I'll try to
get those videos out as fast as possible
but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Alex love please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round of this video on ounce
the winner when I post that flash
trailer while you wait for that click
here for my non-spoilery video for the
first half of iron fist and click here
to learn more about stab ATAR thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video